they've come from far and wide they're
on the rooftops here at Market Square
thousands of people have come here to
Kingston Ontario for The Tragically hips
last show a band that has been at it for
so many years that has meant so much to
Canadians and to music fans around the
world I've met Americans I met Canadians
I've met so many people that love The
Tragically Hip and it's such an honor to
be here in Kingston Ontario back where
it all began for The Tragically Hip you
this is you are
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a night where all of Canada's
descending on Kingston it's a night for
celebration it's a night to
unfortunately say goodbye and and at the
same time to remember who we are as
Canadians
[Applause]
[Music]
the sounds of the hip have been the
sounds of soundtrack to my life into so
many of us in so many ways we started
here as you know and open up to 13
people
and our next show we had 28
and then the next Kingston show after
that we had six gourd filled the crowd
with laughs cheers and tears even
getting emotional at times
the hit played for two and a half hours
with no commercial breaks and there was
not one not two but three touching on
course officially into uncharted waters
we never do third ones
tragically yep not these guys it's
bittersweet of course because we want
more and who knows right we say final
show but who knows who knows what's
gonna happen maybe you know there's
miracles and heroes just gonna have to
look forward but I think the guys are
really happy and I think this has been a
fantastic story
I don't really know other band in any
other country in the world has United a
country like The Tragically Hip so
cheers to The Tragically Hip we love The
Tragically Hip even south of the border
stars were sending their love to the
band
Pearl Jam's Eddie Vetter pay tribute to
the hip in Chicago on Saturday I just
want to send him our energy from our
gathering up to there gathering up there
[Applause]
No
[Applause]